My name is Anet Brea de Cortez.
I am from Panama...
...and I come here as a participant of the TEA program...
...given to us by the State Department of United States of America.
It is coordinated also with George Mason University at Fairfax, Virginia.
We are learning a lot of current trends of education...
...and also we are having some field experience at Holmes Middle School.
I know very little of the world.
I don't get outside of the United States very often,...
...and so this is almost a modern form of travel for me...
...because my students and I learn together...
...and so my students see me model learning, as well as teaching.
And the fellows who come here are highly qualified...
...and my students sense that almost immediately.
And I also have asked to go and observe all their classes...
...because I am so interested in assessment.
I have shared with her many of the rubrics that we use.
She tells me that she plans to put those into use in her country.